Pablo Picasso was alive when humans
first walked on the moon when asked what
he thought about it he replied it means
nothing to me I have no opinion about it
and I don't care
everyone else they talked to was more
interested the Dalai Lama called it an
epic making event sculptor Jacques
Lipschitz said we would never be the
same as a species he called it a
mutation of humanity Charles Evers the
mayor of Fayette Mississippi said the
billions of dollars being spent on the
moon exploration program means that it
will be even longer before America
begins to keep her promises to the poor
America needs to look at Earth not at
space and poet Paul Goodman said it's
good to waste money on such a moral and
aesthetic Venture these are our
Cathedrals we ought to see to it that
people live well but a part of living
well is blowing money on big excitement
curiosity entertainment and conversation
[Music]